welcome to joe biden's america
[Applause]
take a look at this disturbing
surveillance video out of la
this is a jewish father of six on his
way to synagogue running for his life
two cars sped toward him they appear to
be flying palestinian flags
they meant to get him and they didn't
they were not saying any racial slurs
they said allah akbar
which we know very well unfortunately
means they would like to commit a
terrorist attack
hurt someone kill someone now the recent
spate of vicious attacks against jewish
americans shouldn't surprise anyone
the fact is anti-semitism has been
comfortably housed
inside the black lives matter movement
and just like attacks against police
officers are tolerated and even
celebrated by blm activists so are
attacks against jews
it's disgusting it has the biden
administration
in a bind of its own making the
democrats
right now are obsessing on a commission
to investigate that two and a half hour
capital riot on january 6th
but they're turning a blind eye to the
explosion of crime
on the streets of america and they
simply refuse to confront
the anti-semitic cross currents in both
the blm and the critical race theory
crowd
so by refusing to renounce the far
left's push
to defund the police and instead
choosing a target police practices
the biden doj has made life in america
more dangerous for everyone
and by refusing to call out the vile
anti-jewish sentiments expressed by
their own allies
democrats have made america far more
dangerous for jews
the origin of the thuggish tactics of
the emboldened anti-semite
semites tracked the tactics of blm thugs
last summer
this was the scene tuesday in west l.a
as described by an eyewitness
a large caravan of people waving
palestinian flags
as they drove through several
neighborhoods members of the caravan who
approached the restaurant began throwing
bottles at diners outside
and using anti-semitic slurs it was a
hate crime the witness told cbsla
it was prepared they came to fight with
jewish people
another witness told the station that
dozens of men
ran from the caravan toward the
restaurant asking
who's jewish now does that remind you of
anything
[Applause]
[Music]
now in both cases these intimidation
tactics go unpunished
as liberal wokesters cower in fear
and the agitators they feel empowered
because
they have the cover of members of
congress
such as of course elon omar
alexandria ocasio-cortez and cory bush
palestinians know what state violence
militarized policing and occup
and occupation of their communities look
like and they've lived that reality
of having to go through checkpoints
while trying to live their lives they
know
this reality and the reality of so much
more
so when heavily militarized police
forces showed up in ferguson in 2014
bassam and so many others of our saint
louis palestinian
community our our palestinian siblings
showed up
too and the co-founder of the boycott
divest and sanctions movement
also smears israel with that same
systemic racism analogy that blm
uses against america when apartheid
ended in south africa did that end the
existence of
south africans no it just ended an
unjust
oppressive system when jim crow ended in
in the united states south did that end
the existence of alabama
no it ended a very racist
institutionalized racist system
that's exactly what we're calling for
and in tandem with the racial grievance
industry in the u.s
anti-jewish forces use selective viral
video clips
in an attempt to indoctrinate the next
generation
the images that people are seeing on
social media they cannot unsee
and i think that you have changes that
are going on things like the tulsa riots
things like black lives matter are seen
as connected
by a very large number of people not
just in the democratic party but
particularly
particularly young people on campuses
young people all over the country on
campuses
well meanwhile in tweets anti-semite
elon omar accused
israel of running an apartheid state and
engaging in terrorism
and then demanded that israel answer for
war crimes and last week her fellow
squad member
rashida tlaib revealed how blm
radicalism
does share common cause with the
anti-israel movement
all freedom is interconnected with black
brown indigenous
what they are doing to the palestinian
people
is what they continue to do to our black
brothers and sisters here
this is how you grow this movement this
is how you spread the truth
in fact the co-founder of blm cites her
trip to palestine
as a key influence we went on a
solidarity trip
and i think it it transformed all of us
it transformed how we understood
the palestinian struggle but also how we
understood it in relationship
to black people's struggle inside the
u.s and i think it was
a profound moment of clarity i think
that's been
incredibly powerful for our movement the
fact is
israel has been america's most loyal
ally in the middle east since its
founding
during trump's first term progress
toward peace was being made
slowly but surely with those abraham
accords
but president biden is well on his way
to blowing all of it
by sidling up to the marxist black lives
matter movement
by embracing the use of this poisonous
critical race theory in schools
and by refusing to tackle the social
pathologies at the heart of urban crime
biden has not only made america more
divided and dangerous
he spawned a terrifying wave of
anti-semitic attacks
that could quickly spiral out of control
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else